das ist ein forschungsergebnis das alles
infrage stellt müssen wir die dunkle
materie noch mal ganz neu denken ihre
existenz scheint klar doch die suche
nach den konkreten teilchen die ihr
zugrunde liegen ist weiterhin
ergebnislos eine neue studie aus
südkorea wirft neue zweifel auf ob es
die teilchen der dunklen materie die
vielversprechenden wings tatsächlich
gibt oder ist die dunkle materie etwas
ganz anderes klicks umsatz im future
hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasste nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen haben wir die
mysteriöse dunkle materie schon längst
gefunden die rede ist von den
sogenannten weekly interacting massive
particles kurz übersetzt etwa soviel wie
schwach wechsel wirkende massereiche
teilchen man geht davon aus dass die
auch als schwächlinge bezeichneten
partikel eine große masse haben
elektrisch neutral sind und eben nur in
geringem umfang mit anderen teilchen
wechselwirken doch diese dunkle materie
teilchen sind bislang nur hypothetisch
und wurden einzig und allein
vorhergesagt um das dunkle materie
problem zu verstehen und somit wäre die
entdeckung und der nachweis dieser muss
sicherlich einen nobelpreis wert bilden
diese mysteriöse teams also die dunkle
materie diese macht schätzung zufolge
bis zu 27 prozent des universums aus
hinzu kommen noch knapp 69 dunkle
energie die normale sichtbare materie im
universum also alle galaxien sterne und
eben auch wir machen dagegen nur einen
winzigen anteil von 4,9 prozent aus das
sagt der aktuelle stand der physik
vorstellen kann man sich die dunkle
materie demnach vielleicht als sehr
feinen und nicht sichtbaren nebel der
zwischen den sternen war butt doch
obwohl sie nicht direkt sichtbar ist
macht sich die dunkle materie indirekt
bemerkbar und zwar durch ihre
gravitation die ganze galaxien um sich
gruppiert und die auseinander fliegen
würden wenn es die dunkle materie nicht
gäbe den gängigen theorien zufolge ist
dunkle materie also durch ihre als eine
art klebstoff dafür verantwortlich dass
das universum überhaupt existiert das
große problem aber für die fachwelt
dunkle materie ist unsichtbar sie sendet
weder licht aus noch reflektiert sie
dieses noch nie hat sie irgend jemand
gesehen oder eben teilchen gefunden
aus der sie bestehen direkter nachweis
steht also bis heute aus oder
beziehungsweise ist noch nicht endgültig
bewiesen doch mit der hilfe des so
genannten damalige experiments in einem
italienischen gebirgsmassiv will ein
forschungsteam die mysteriöse namens
aufgespürt haben damals steht für dark
matter also für die dunkle materie hier
werden die rektoren aus nach rom judith
genutzt um die potenziellen teilchen der
dunklen materie auf die schliche zu
kommen wenn die unsichtbaren teilchen
der dunklen materie durch die patriot
kristalle team durch rasen sollen sie
hin und wieder an einem atomkern streuen
und lichtblitze aus senden schon vor
einigen jahren wollen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hier mit der hilfe des riesigen
direktors aus natrium mio den signale
von rims beobachtet haben dazu der
physiker florian reindl wir haben etwas
gefunden aber es ist ein sehr mysteriös
signal doch das problem bisher konnten
keine anderen experimente die weltweit
stattfinden solche teilchen spuren
entdecken fest steht um die mysteriöse
dunkle materie wirklich sicher
nachzuweisen braucht es ähnliche
ergebnisse in anderen experimenten denn
so funktioniert die wissenschaft man
könnte quasi sagen einmal ist keinmal
dazu die physikerin frederica die mit
der hilfe des kress experiments nach
dunkler materie sucht die dame
kollaboration hat zweifelsohne ein
signal entdeckt das mit der erwartung
für dunkle materie kompatibel wäre aber
so eine entdeckung sollte von einem
unabhängigen experiment überprüft werden
und tatsächlich gibt es zahlreiche
projekte weltweit die die damals signale
reproduzieren wollen unter anderem an
eis in spanien wo sie nie 100 in
südkorea und dem eis in der antarktis
auch hier will man mit der hilfe von
natrium judith direktor der dunkle
materie auf die schliche kommen bisher
konnte aber keine experimente
die indizien für dunkle materie
bestätigen dann liegt das ist die
datenlage möglicherweise noch zu dünn
oder wurde die nachweis schwelle nicht
erreicht die zweifel am dammer
experiment werden immer lauter und jetzt
das zur enttäuschung vieler
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
lässt eine neue studie aus südkorea die
ohnehin bestehenden zweifel an der
existenz der imz wachsen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die das cuisine er 100 experimente
betreuen haben jetzt ihre ergebnisse von
der suche nach teilchen signalen
veröffentlicht wie ist das fazit des
forschungsteams und warum findet sich
einfach weit und breit kein einziges web
müssen wir unsere idee von der
mysteriösen dunklen materie überdenken
viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass die
dunkle materie aus noch unentdeckten
elementarteilchen besteht diese gehen
wohl auf den urknall vor 13 8 milliarden
jahren zurück wodurch das heutige
universum überhaupt es entstand diese
mysteriösen dunklen materie teilchen
sind der theorie zufolge in der lage
einfach alles im universum einfach so zu
durchqueren diese eigenschaft hat die
partikel auch zu ihrem namen gebracht
schwach wechsel wirkende massereiche
teilchen man geht davon aus dass die
auch als schwächlinge bezeichneten
partikel eine große masse haben
elektrisch neutral sind und eben nur in
geringem umfang mit anderen teilchen
wechselwirken und dennoch will man beim
damals experiment fündig geworden sein
doch an diesem ergebnis gibt es zweifel
vor fünf jahren 2016 hatte man dann das
cousine 100 experiment in süd korea
gestartet um das italienische experiment
und möglicherweise auch seine ergebnisse
zu reproduzieren
der versuchsaufbau wurde also
tatsächlich an den start gebracht um die
dahmer ergebnisse unabhängig zu prüfen
können die vips signale also widerlegt
oder aber bestätigt werden bereits nach
60 tagen beobachtungszeit ein
ernüchterndes ergebnis demnach konnte
man das damals signal mit hilfe des
kozany 100 experiments nicht
reproduzieren doch die hoffnung stirbt
zuletzt und dieses vorläufige resultat
galt nur für eine sorte von wenn es
möglicherweise aber zeichnen sich diese
hypothetische teilchen durch andere
eigenschaften aus möglicherweise sind
sie massereicher oder weniger masse
erreicht als gedacht oder aber reagiert
der südkoreanische detector auch anders
als sein italienisches pondorf die
fachleute waren also weiterhin
optimistisch die messung aus italien mit
denen aus südkorea in einklang zu
bringen der südkoreanische
versuchsaufbau liegt 700 meter unter der
erde so will man nach dem signal suchen
knapp zwei jahre lang von 2016 bis 2018
hat man hier forschungsergebnisse
generiert und genau die haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
jetzt veröffentlicht demnach konnten
keinerlei hinweise auf das im dahmer
experiment aufgespürte signal gefunden
werden das konnten also keinerlei
anzeichen dafür gefunden werden das
potenziell existierende wilms mit dem
detektor interagiert haben dazu sagt
eine der beteiligten physikerin gizmodo
rainer-maria unser team hat
herausgefunden dass das was da mal
beobachtet hat unter den meisten
grundlegenden annahmen darüber dreams
mit gewöhnlicher materie interagieren
sollten nicht die dunkle materie sein
kann das ergebnis reiht sich also in die
ergebnisse vorheriger untersuchungen ein
vollkommen widerlegt ist das damals
signal aber dennoch nicht denn dafür
müssten noch weitere daten gesammelt
werden über jahre hinweg hinzu kommt
dass ein weiterer punkt noch genauer
untersucht werden soll dazu die
physikerin gizmodo reiner kramer wir
haben die von damals beobachtete
jährliche modulation die laut damals auf
dunkle materie zurückzuführen ist noch
nicht eingehend getestet das ist unser
nächstes ziel die rede ist hier von
einer jahreszeitlich auftretenden
schwankungen bei den beobachteten
signalen hier liegt der höhepunkt im
juni der grund dafür das sonnensystem
kreist um den mittelpunkt der
milchstraße und die erde um die sonne so
addieren sich je nach position die
beiden relativen geschwindigkeiten nicht
nur die erde sondern auch die detektoren
erleben somit mal einen stärkeren mal
einen schwächeren teilchen sind auch das
damals forschungsteam hat sich auch
schon zur neuen studie aus südkorea
geäußert laut der italienischen
physikerin rita werner bei würden die
cousine 100 ergebnisse nichts an der
untersuchung der dunkle materie ändern
ihrer meinung nach seien die beiden
experimente nicht identisch und somit
nicht vergleichbar die methodik des
cousine 100 experiment kann ihrer
meinung nach zu großen unsicherheiten
und verzerrungen führen der physiker dan
hopper fasst es in einem interview mit
gizmodo folgendermaßen zusammen dennoch
waren wir uns alle einig dass es am
überzeugendsten wäre wenn ein experiment
durchgeführt werden könnte bei dem genau
die gleiche art von ziel material
verwendet wird wie bei damals ich weiß
immer noch nicht was damals sieht
vielleicht ist es ein seltsamer
hintergrund oder einfach ein fehler den
sie irgendwie gemacht haben aber was
auch immer vor sich geht jetzt scheint
nichts mit dunkler materie zu tun zu
haben oder vielleicht ist die dunkle
materie auch das was der
wissenschaftliche direktor der esa
günther hasinger bei uns bei klicks um
im exklusiv-interview vermutet schwarze
löcher erklären die dunkle materie
schwarzes loch in unserem sonnensystem
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran